first of all this looks awesome
the expected still look kind of hard
don't you
it's not soft so there's stuff in the
middle not red bean it's like sticky
both teens sweet its crunchy its chewy
it's very interactive dessert which I
like you get to pick it up and play with
it and like squish it and like pull it
apart that's fun
done touch done touch done Tut well that
bite is really interesting I'm fun and
new very edgy like you really taste the
egg it doesn't taste like creamy milky
sugar it's like a mini pie mini egg pie
now looks like a soup like a desert soup
that's weird
now you say having a soup for dessert
this is so good it just has an
interesting texture
it's like tea with stuff at the bus
here's how I judge things taste
adorableness that's the end oh he's very
jealous
it tastes like condensed milk and mango
mixed together texture is right in the
middle between pudding and jello these
desserts have an element of fun I'm not
gonna lie it's like it tastes good but
then it's also a lot of fun I see the
little balls everywhere it's like a
little party in your mouth it smells
bomb it's really good with the mango cuz
the mango is nice and tart and like the
coconut cream is just like it's like a
little sweep of mostly neutral so it
like balances it all out really well
this is like the freshest dessert of all
time this is the best my favorite is the
sesame ball easily the black sesame soup
was actually really fun and different
I really like the Dom time and I set it
right thank you hi my love is that right
yep that was the best one that was the
best one by far the assessment balls are
kind of magical like they're kind of
like made out of magic I think those
balls were two thumbs up for Hong Kong
desserts